let me ask you this
it's also heartbreaking to me on the
topic of cancer culture yeah so in the
machine learning community i've seen it
a little bit
that there's um aggressive
attacking of people who are trying to
have a nuanced conversation about things
and it's troubling because it feels like
nuanced conversation is the only way to
talk about difficult topics
and when there's a thought police and
speech police
on any nuance conversation that
everybody has to like in uh
animal farm chant that racism is bad
and sexism is bad which is things that
everybody believes
and they're they can't possibly say
anything nuance
it feels like it goes against any kind
of progress
from my kind of shallow perspective but
you've written a little bit about cancer
culture
did you have thoughts that are well look
i mean i mean
to say that i am opposed to you know the
this trend of of cancellations or of you
know shouting people down rather than
engaging them
that would be a massive understatement
right and i feel like you know i have
put my money where my mouth is you know
not as much as some people have
but you know i i've i've tried to do
something i mean i have
defended you know uh some unpopular
people and
unpopular you know ideas on my blog
i've you know tried to defend you know
norms of uh
of uh of of open discourse of you know
reasoning with our opponents even when
i've been shouted down for that on uh
social media uh you know called a racist
called a sexist all of those things and
which by the way i should say you know i
would be perfectly happy to you know say
you know if we had time to say you know
you know ten thousand times you know my
uh hatred
of racism of sexism of homophobia right
but what i don't want to do is to cede
to uh some particular political faction
the right to define
exactly what is meant by those terms to
say well then you have to agree with all
of these other
extremely contentious positions or else
you are a misogynist or else you are a
racist right
i say that well no you know you know
don't like
don't i or you know don't people like me
also get a say
in the discussion about you know what is
racism
about what is going to be the most
effective to combat racism
right and you know this this this um
cancellation mentality i think is
spectacularly ineffective
at its own professed goal of you know
combating racism and sexism
what's a positive way out so i i try to
i don't know if you see what i do on
twitter but i on twitter i mostly and in
my whole
in my life i've actually it's who i am
to the core is like
i really focus on the positive and i try
to put love out there in the world
yeah and still i get
attacked and i look at that and i wonder
like
are you two i didn't know like i haven't
actually said anything
difficult and nuanced you talk about
somebody like
steven pinker yeah who i actually don't
know the full range of
things that um that he's attacked for
but
he tries to say difficult he tries to be
thoughtful about
difficult topics he does and obviously
he just gets
slaughtered by well i mean i mean i mean
i mean yes but it's also amazing how
well steve has withstood it i mean he
just survived that attempt to cancel him
just a couple of months ago right
psychologically he survives it too which
yeah worries me yeah i've gotten to know
steve a bit
he is incredibly unperturbed by this
stuff
and i admire that and i envy it i wish
that i could be like that
i mean my impulse when i'm getting
attacked is i just want to engage
every single like anonymous person on
twitter
and reddit who is saying mean stuff
about me and i wanted to say well look
can we just talk this over for an hour
and then you know
you'll see that i'm not that bad you
know sometimes that even works
the problem is then there's the you know
the twenty thousand other ones
right that's not but psychologically
does that wear on you
it it does it does but yeah i mean in
terms of what is the solution i mean i
wish i knew right and so you know
in a certain way these problems are
maybe harder than p versus np
right i mean uh you know but but i think
that
part of it has to be for you know that i
think that there's a lot of
sort of silent support for what i'll
call the the
the open discourse side the you know
reasonable enlightenment side
and i think that that that support has
to become less silent
right i think that a lot of people uh
this sort of you know
like agree that oh you know a lot of
these cancellations and attacks are
ridiculous
but are just afraid to say so right or
else they'll get they'll get shouted
down as well
right that's just the standard witch
hunt dynamic which you know of course
this uh you know this faction
understands and exploits to its great
advantage
but um you know uh if more people just
you know said you know like we're not
going to stand for this
right uh uh you know you know this is
this is you know
where guess what we're against racism
too but you know
this you know what you're doing is
ridiculous right
um you know and the hard part is like it
takes a lot of mental energy it takes a
lot of time
you know even if you feel like you're
not going to be cancelled or you know
you're staying on the safe side
like it takes a lot of time to uh to to
phrase things in exactly the right way
and to uh
you know respond to everything people
say so but i think that
um you know the more people speak up
than uh uh you know from from
from all political persuasions you know
from like
all you know walks of life then you know
the the easier it is to move forward
you